but as you can tell by certain things
that are behind me uh i am a little bit
of a marvel fan and i really do want to
ask you uh if you can tease anything
about the ant-man movie that i believe
you might be filming
i i can tease that i am currently
filming quantum mania
and um i can tease nothing else for you
lest i die
sure can i at least ask you what was
your reaction uh after reading the
script was one of these things where you
were just like
if you could talk about that i would be
happy to i was
so stoked on the script jeff loveness is
our new writer for the for the film and
we've never worked with him before
and i think he is phenomenal i think
he's one of the best writers we've ever
had i think he's got an incredible
mastery of voice so on the page i could
hear all the characters and and i knew
that he really kind of
harnessed
each person's unique personality and um
and i just think that it's gonna be
it's it's gonna be really special i
think it's gonna be really good i
actually think it has the chance to be
the best one we've done yet
yeah i can't i cannot wait my last thing
for you um
do you actually pay attention to all the
other no it's not about ant-man uh
you know i just love the genuine
enthusiasm i can feel it
oh yeah i actually really care about the
stuff the but i'm curious do you
actually watch all the other
marvel things the animation i know you
did what if are you watching all this to
sort of make sure that you're like in
the loop as if you understand everything
that's going on are you almost watching
it now because you mentioned you have a
son who is a fan are you now watching
everything like with your son and sort
of taking it in through his eyes in a
completely new way
a bit of both and a bit of neither i i
have not seen all of it
and i and i do try i sort of it i see it
as almost like homework like i i need to
i need to know what's going on in the
world i need to understand when there's
references made in scripts you know i
need to know what's going on um i'm also
a fan of marvel
as in i'm a fan of the filmmakers that
that are you know creating this
incredible universe i think
they are the best superhero
movie makers i've ever witnessed i and i
know that i'm not alone in that so
that's not a revolutionary thing to say
except that i don't actually like
superhero movies so coming from me
that's different i i think they're
really smart i think they're really
really really good at what they do and
it's why i wanted to get involved with
this franchise um you know i never had
any desire to be in a superhero movie
but
marvel do it right they do it really
well so i'm a fan like i i think wanda
vision was
phenomenal and i think it was
probably the best they've ever
represented a female character it was so
incredible to see her be so complicated
and so flawed and yet so redeemable and
so lovable um the way we have typically
historically treated our male characters
i think it was an epic female
protagonist story
um i loved
loved the ending of loki the loki tv
show i they didn't fully have me till
the end i was like okay okay sure yeah
okay it's good but i wasn't like oh my
god this is an amazing show
until they got to the end and i was like
it's chaos theory i love it i love it i
love it you know like like the science
geek in me
loves that element of how smart they are
and how they tackle such enormous topics
that
most kind of fluff popcorn movies are
not going to tackle
they tackled chaos theory that's really
brave and really bold and really cool um
so yeah i don't watch them all i still
haven't seen my one f episode which i'm
dying to see because i had so much fun
making it but i will i'll catch up on it
eventually i still haven't seen black
widow but i will i i'm you know i have
intentions to i haven't seen the
uh
what's anthony mackie's show called
falcon and winter soldier yes i haven't
seen falcon winter soldier yet i will
you know i just it takes there's so many
things i can't i but i've definitely not
seen them all i actually had one
division and local are the only tv shows
i've seen from marvel
yeah i i
i mean i could just dig deep on this but
i'll just say that with loki i agree
with you that ending is amazing because
jonathan majors is telling them the
truth that and it's just this great and
he's so good in it um and he's telling
them you know you might get someone a
lot worse than me like you you're you
know what i mean it's so good
it's so good and the fact that
when when we explore the two sides to
chaos theory it's two sides of the same
person is so
good because i don't know about you but
i have both those people in me i mean i
have that constant battle inside of me
especially right now with the way the
world is today of like
how much do we control and how much do
we need freedom and where is that
balance and what does that look like and
what's more important safety or freedom
and that's what they're tackling in this
show and the fact that tackling it in
2021 postpending well
mid pandemic
you know is is really
brave and bold and um
yeah i dig it
you